でしたので その時の 先回
我々の意識の中で いわゆる慰問の方でどのように認識過程が起こるかということは説明しただろうと思います
で 人間の場合はこのよく我々よくやっているのは考えることなんですね
で 目から耳から入る情報についてはほとんど知識がないんです
で ただまあ見えただけ
聞こえただけで終わっちゃうんです
で その見えたもの 聞こえたものを我々が頭の中で
胃の中で まあ自分好きな方向でプロセッシングするんですね
まあいろんな作業して
認識として 知識として処理して
まあ使うんですね ですからこの
人間 この世の中に対して知ってること
で 厳密に言えば全くその通りですよということは言えないんですね
で 私が何かを見て 見たものは頭の中で
認識して理解するんですね
ですから その機能働きっていうのは
別にそれなりに変わってない起こることなんです
そういうことで 我々世の中でいろんな異論あるということはありますね
何かについて いろんな人がいろんな意見を持ってるんですね
もし我々の認識っていうものがしっかりした正しいものであるならば
人間の間でいろんな違う意見があるはずがないんです
ですから どんな人間 二人取っても全く同じ意見でいるということはまるっきりないことなんです
そのその自分が自分の認識世界持っているんです
それですから 互いに人間っていうのは
いろんなものについて違う意見
違う概念を持って戦ったり混乱したりするんです
それも一つの人間にある問題で
生きる時 社会人として生きる時は我々に出てくる一つの問題なんですね
で 家族にしたっても 家族の考え方は決して同じじゃないんです
バラバラなんです 兄弟の考え方もバラバラで
ですから 家族としてまとまるということは大変なことなんです
で 私たちは社会に入って
みんなで仲良くしようと思ったっても
もうそれはなかなかできないものなんです
厳密に言えばできるはずもない
で なぜかというと そのその人が自分の意見という自分の世界を持ってるんだから
で 我々は目に見えるもの
耳に触れるもの 鼻で嗅ぐもの
それはその通りにありのまま理解するならば
人間の間でそういう違う意見が現れるはずがないんですね
ですから この何か目で見て
見たものについてほとんど知識がないんです
ただ何か目に入った それだけ
で それについて胃の中で胃っていうのは意識ですね
慰問の中で概念としてそれを回転しちゃうんですね
それで私が自分が見たものについて
それは綺麗なものですよと綺麗じゃないものですよとか
なんとか思うかもしれません
私は感動しましたと 私はつまらなかったとかね
私と一緒にいる人が全く違う意見を持ってる可能性があるんですね
ですから 私は何か見て
ああ すごい綺麗なものですよ
感動しましたと言っても
それは決して普遍的な真理ではないんです
ただ 私だけ この生命の中でたった一人だけそう思うことなんですね
そこで一緒にいる人は
いや それはもうつまらないものだと
感動はしませんでしたと言ったら
それもその人だけ思っていることで
ですから 世の中で人間というのは同じ意見を持ってるわけがないんです
同じ認識を持ってるわけじゃないんです
そこで人間のもう一つ問題っていうのは
そこら辺アビダルマで後になってくると説明出てきますけど
自分思ったりすること
自分考えたりすることは正しいんだと思ってるんですね
なぜならば私の経験だから
私はそう感じたんだからということで
まあ証拠は要りませんね
例えば自分が何か食べ物を食べると
食べて 自分があまりにも美味しくて感動しましたと
それは本人に対しての事実だから
それに証拠はいりませんね
こういうわけで この食べ物はおいしいですよという必要はないんだ
自分の経験だから それでこの食べ物はおいしい食べ物ですよと
その人は意見を持つようになっちゃうんです
で 他の人同じものを食べてみたら
もしかするとおいしくなかったかもしれませんし
感動しなかったかもしれません
それでその人とこの人が二人がやっぱりもう相違点が出てきて戦うんですね
それで残念ながら人間に限って仲良くすることは不可能なんですね
で そういう世界で私たちは何か考え方を持って
なんかみんな仲良くしましょうと
なんか強引に頑張ってはいるんです
例えば政治的な概念を持って
この概念に賛成する人々はみんな一緒になりましょうというふうに
一つのグループが出来上がる
あるいは宗教的な概念を持って
この概念に賛成する人々は一緒になろうではないかとか
いろんな概念 その勝手に作っちゃうんですね
作ってみんないろいろグループを作る
そのグループは他のグループと戦う
あなた方は間違っているんだと
仏教で言うのは これ 誰の知識にしたっても大したことではありません
単なるその人はそう思っただけ
全然信憑性も真理 真実性もないんだと
そこは理解できれば その人は世の中で誰とも戦おうとしない
その人は自分で何か私はこの意見だよと思って
高慢で我を張って 世の中で
もうそういう風に何か威張って生きていようとは思わないんですね
何も意見持てない立派な人間になるんですね
ですから この心の法則
物事をどのように生滅変化していくんだということは
智慧をもって体験するべきですよと
体験したところで 世の中と何も逆らうこともなくなるんだと
それだけではなくて 世の中のどんな意見にも別に見せられることでも
囚われることでも 嫌になることでも
何のことなくクールにいられるんですね
で そこは仏教の智慧の世界
だからいくらかのこのアビダンマやらいろんな勉強で我々何やっていますかというと
この悟るために必要な七覚支がございまして
そこで 2番目は択法覚支と言うんですね
1番目は念覚支 もうサティをもって実践すること
2番目はもう択法覚支と言うんですけど
漢字はちょっとわかりませんだけど
あのダンマ・ヴィチャヤとパーリ語で言うんですね
ダンマ・ヴィチャヤ このヴィチャヤというのは
というのは この明確に分析して区別してよく理解することなんですね
これはこういうもの これはこういうものやと
全く別々にできるだけ物事を分析して明確に理解すること
だからこの明確な分析能力
で 智慧のために必要なんですね
で 分析することには まあ分別能力と言ってもいいんですけど
で それに嫌いな人々もいるんです
やっぱり全部別々に分析する必要はないんだと
全部まとめたところで真実はあるんだという考え方あるんだけど
それは全く違うと私は思います
なぜならば 人間というのはまとめた幻覚しか知らないし
ですからまとめた幻覚を知っていたっていうのは智慧にはならないんですね
なぜその幻想がまとめられたかということは理解するべきなんですね
例えば 現代 我々が使っている何か機械を理解するとき
それはまとめて理解したとしても
その機械を理解したことにならないんですね
それは一つ一つ部品を分解して
一つ一つ部品がどんな仕事をしているんですかと
どんな役割があるんですかと知った人だけ
その機械のことを知ってるんです
ですから 分析能力っていうのは確実に必要なんです
そういうことで この説法をするときでも
アビダンマやらいろんなお経を勉強するときでも
我々が目指しているのはたった一つ
このダンマヴィジャヤという能力
物事を分析して理解できるようにする能力をなんとか身についてもらいたいという気持ちなんです
ですから このこの意識の働きの場合も
見たもの聞いたものを自分勝手に概念を作ったりして
自分の概念が正しいと思ったりすることによって
世の中の苦しみ 戦い生まれてくる
そこから自我が生まれてくる
私という概念がそこで実感が生まれてくる
私はこう思ってるんだからとか
私はこういう主義だよとか
で それで他人と自分を区別しちゃう
区別してもう他人と戦っちゃうんです
そういうことで生きるということは
大変な苦しみになってしまうんですね
寂しくなってしまうんです
自分が孤立しているんだから
そこで似ている意見がある人がいるんですけど
探して色々グループは作る
家族を作る 社会を作る
でもそれで平和な社会を作るかというと
全くそうじゃないんです
家族を作ったところで
そこで喧嘩ばっかりになっちゃうし
社会を作ったところで
そこでお互いに争いばっかりになってくるし
作れるわけじゃないんです
本当のところは ということで
真理を知っている人は社会から離れるんだと
全く一人で生活するんだと
スッタニパータで出てくる有名な経がありますね
犀の如く一人でいると
それはもう聖者の仕方なんですね
で それで寂しいかというと
そうじゃなくて あれは堂々たる発言なんですね
私には一人で生きていられるということ
まあこの次の話に行く前に
そういうアビダンマから教えようとしている
仏教から教えしている
この哲学的なところ まず覚えておいてください
テキストではそういう話は出てこないんです
なぜならば そういうのは人間が自分で発見しなきゃこの百目がないんです
効き目がないんです 今私が言ったことも
皆様方ご自分で眼耳鼻舌身の働きと意の働き
そういうものかと自分で観察したところで分かったならば
これすごい人生変わっちゃうんですね
私の話を聞いても 別にそんなに他人の意見だからね
あまり効き目がないんです
ですから そういうことをアビダンマテキストでは教えていないし
経典アビダンマ経典がありますけど
そちらでも出てこない
その知ってほしいところは別においておくんですね
自分でそこは発見しなさいと
[背景音]まあそういうこと言いたかっていうのも
一つポイントがありまして
人間の知識っていうのはそんなにそれほど大した大事な知識ではありませんということなんです
我々知識によってすごい苦労している
勉強しなくちゃいけないとかね
図書館にしたっても ものすごい膨大な図書館ばっかりあったりして
一人の人間にそれは全く読めないし
それでありとあらゆる工夫をして
すぐ自分の手に情報が入るようにとかね
いろんな工夫をして膨大なお金がかかったりして
で 苦労してはいるんだけど
それは得て何かなるかというと
全く何にもならないんです
どんな情報を得たって
アメリカ何やってるんですか？イラクは何やってる？知っていたとしても何のことにもならないんです
今の国の状態どうですか？とかね
もし人間真実知ってるならば
異論あるはずがないんです
例えば経済状態悪いという
それだったら良くするためにどうすればいいかと聞けば
答えが出てこないか いろんなこと答えが出てくる
それで答えの間でまた戦い
いえ それやったらダメ
これやれば？なんでそうなるんで
もし問題あるならば その問題に答えがあるはずでしょうに
経済状態が悪っていうことは問題であるならば
それにそれだったらこうするべきですよという確実な答えがあるはずでしょうに
なんで出てこないんですかね
ですから 智慧のある人にはそういう答えも出てくるんです
なぜか 例えば経済状態悪いというこの現象を分析すると
経済学者がまたいろいろ意見を言うんですね
ですから 問題さえ理解していないんですね
結局自分の意見言ってるんですね
自分が自分の体に入った情報は自分勝手に認識して
それを自分の意見として言うと
それは他の人の意見とはもう関係ないんですね
そこで人間やってることは
この暴力を 知識暴力を使うんですね
この知識暴力を振って自分の意見にみんな抑えておく
例えば日本で国際的な大変有名なこのもう天才みたいな経済学者がいるとしたならば
みんなに認められていたと
世界的に認められている人だと
天才だと ノーベル賞も取っているんだという風な
いろいろ肩書いっぱい持ってる人が何か意見を言ったならば
あの人もそう言ってるんだからと言って
その人の意見にみんなサーッと行ってしまっちゃうんです
ああいうのは私の立場から言えば知識暴力なんです
別にその人暴力振ってるわけじゃないんだけど
自分の意見を喋るだけかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり自分が社会的な持っている立場
自分の人気 そういうものを使って相手を圧倒する
させると それ暴力なんです
ですから 世の中である人の意見にみんなまとめられたというのは
まあ世俗 この世界ではね
ただの知識 暴力だけしか何もないんです
政治世界ではやっぱり暴力的な人こそみんな抑えておくでしょうに
リーダーシップ取るでしょうに
よくプレゼンあるとかね
まあリーダーシップあるっていうのはもう暴力なんですね
結局は人を抑えておくと
で そういうことを理解すると
我々にはこの世の中に対する関わり
世の中から我々へと向かうと言われる苦しみっていうのは消えちゃうんですね
世の中に入りたくてみんな必死なんですね
接続の世界に入りたいと
でも入れないんです 皆様は社会人だから社会人になりたいと思ってるんだけど
入れない 社会人にならないんです
みんな非社会人なんです
自分には自分の意見ありますから
それは社会の意見とは違うんだから
それなのに社会人 社会のメンバーになりたくはないんです
そこでもう一つ理解してほしいことは
社会というものありますかと
社会ということはないんです
ないもののメンバーになりたがっちゃうんです
私は日本の立派な社会人になりたいんだと
まあ日本という国はあるんだけど
日本という社会はありません
ですから 存在しない実体のないもののメンバーになろうと思ったっても
ただ苦労しているだけ
何人か人を選んで その人々で仲良くしようとする
それだけのことです その人々は仲良くしてくれない
で パソコンの中でも同じことだから
社会の中でも同じことなんです
で そこを理解できるのは
この慰問の働きを見ると理解できるだろうと思います
慰問のこの意義を説明したと思いますね
で 慰問の場合にはチッタ・ヴィッティ二つありますね
ヴィブータ・アランマナ
アヴィブータ・アランマナ
明瞭と不明瞭というふうな二つあるんですね
この明瞭のヴィッティと不明瞭のヴィッティの差は
この可笑縁という心 二つがない
最後に出てくるただそれだけの差なんです
で 説明すると あのリストとか手元にありますからね
まあただ見てください
このテキストでは百四と百五ページにありますからね
で 我々認識すると 何かをまあしっかりと認識する
あ こういうものを知ったんだというふうな
この納得感ある場合は明瞭のチッタ・ヴィッティなんですね
そうでなくて ただ知ってる状態だったら
不明瞭チッタ・ヴィッティに入っちゃうんですね
その可笑縁縁っていうのは
自分が何を知ったかということについて
なんとなく味わいをするということなんですね
ですから 物事をゆっくりと明確に理解すると
あ これを知りました 次にこれを知りましたというふうに
この明確に知ると不明瞭のチッタ・ヴィッティが生まれる
ただ知るだけだったら不明瞭になっちゃうんです
この前にも説明しましたと思いますけど
この眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報
認識すると心にはそれほど自由はないんです
目から入ったもの それを知ると
自由がないんです で 考える自由はそこでコントロールされるんです
で 現代人が知識だと思っているのはその世界だけなんですね
コントロールされている知識に知識というんです
例えば私に壁を見て あ
これはライオンですよと認識することは不可能なんですね
私は壁ですよと言うし
皆様方も壁を見て壁ですよと言うんです
でも壁ですよと 私の認識と皆様の認識は全く違う別々なものなんですけど
ですから みんなで一緒に同じものを見て同じ経験に立てば
それはあり得ないことなんですが
そこであるコントロールがあるんですね
なぜならば 壁から目に触れる物質的な情報はみんなに同じなんですね
ですから 私は壁を見てライオンだよと認識することは不可能です
皆様にも壁を見て それはライオンじゃなくてキリンですよとというふうに認識することも不可能なんですね
そこら辺認識コントロールしているんです
で 道路の音を聞いて あれはベートーヴェンの音楽だよとかいうことは難しいんですね
その科学的な知識だと
証明ある知識だと しっかりした知識だと
世の中で見ている知識が
そういうふうに原理主義出身の情報によって管理されている
コントロールされている心の働きなんです
そういうことで そういうことから考えても
まあ世の中の知識っていうのは
ただ徹底的にコントロールされている知識だけではないかということはわかるはずなんですね
例えば皆様科学を勉強すると
それはよくわかるだろうと思います
科学の知識というのは徹底してコントロールされている知識なんです
自由に考えることは不可能なんです
科学の世界では いろんな決まり
決まり 決まり 決まりがもうものすごいたくさんあって
その決まりの中で何か認識しなさい
そうでないと科学的な知識にならないんです
だからすごい矛盾なんです
科学世界は自分たちだけ自由だと自由に考えるんだと言うんだけど
その人に限って自由に考えてないんです
ですから 例えば科学的に何か言うならば
その言うことにいろんな決まりがあって
その決まりの中で喋らなくちゃいけない
歴史の勉強の場合も同じなんですね
歴史というのはどのように勉強するか
するべきかということも決まってるんです
その決まりの中で我々頭を働かせちゃうと
すごい知識人だと 思っちゃうんです
ですから この世の中 この膨大な知識だと言ってる知識が
何も膨大でも何でもない
単なるもうありとあらゆる足かせで
もういろんなもう鎖でつなげている
あのちょっとした動きだけなんですね
いわゆるあの空を飛んでいる鳥を私は捕まえて檻に入れちゃう
檻に入れて鳥を観察するんだと
檻の中にいる小さな檻の中に鳥の行動パターンというのは
ものすごく小さくなっちゃうんです
でも それで鳥を全部知ったわけにはならないんですね
眼耳鼻舌身のとにかくから入る情報が
まあコントロールしているんです
自然法則によって そこで意というものは
そういう風にコントロールされるものでもないんです
我々の意識にはどんな認識も作ることは可能なんです
ですから それはアビダンマでこう言うんです
意の対象が過去現在未来のこう全て意対象になるんだと
いわゆる過去っていうのは今ないものなんです
未来っていうのも今ないものなんです
それでも意だけだったら
まあそんなコントロールなしに認識することはできるんだと
それから実際にあるものも実際にないもの
いわゆる現象も意に認識することはできるんだと
アビダンマでこの初めてはこの始めた時は私は二つの言葉を説明してたんですね
サッムティ・サッチャとパラマット・サッチャという
で サッムティっていうのは世の中で真実だよと言っている
そのConventional truthと英語で言うんですね Convention
人々はそうだろうと思う
世論 パラマットっていうのは本当の事実なんですね
正義体系 これにはサッムティには世俗体系と言うんです
体は世俗体の体 世俗体
パラマット・サッチャというのは正義体
優れている意味の 最高の意味の真実と
アビダンマで勉強するのはこの正義体なんですね
パラマット・サッチャ
サッムティ・サッチャではないんです
例えば家ありますよ 机がありますよ
椅子がありますよっていうのは世俗体なんです
世の中の目から見れば
やっぱり机はあるんです
椅子もあるんです アビダンマから見れば
実際にそちらに起こる出来事は
目に何とか形が映ったんだと
その映った形について
意の中で何かプロセスして椅子だよと
後で何か結論を出す その出す結論は世の中で誰でも大体一般的に出すものだから
まあ一般的には認められているんだと
でも実際に起きた出来事は
もう目に普通の我々に見える光が映っただけのことなんです
で 事実見るんだったらね
まあ犬猫も椅子を見て椅子だよと思うかもしれませんだけど
まあそう思わないだろうと思います
椅子ということは 人間にとって真実であって
鳥にとっては別にもう真実でも何でもないんですよ
でも鳥にも見えることは確かに見えるんですね
ですから 鳥の目にも人間の目にも同じ情報が入るんです
アビダンマでこのみんなに入る同じ情報だから
そこら辺で勉強しようとするんですね
椅子の勉強ではなくて
まあその心にはこのパラマットも認識できるし
理解しようと思えば世俗体も認識できるし
あるものもないものも何でも認識できる
幻覚も認識できる で それはまあインド文化では使っている有名な例えなんですけど
暗闇でロープを踏んだと
ロープを踏んだ途端 ヘビだとものすごく驚いて飛び上がっちゃうんです
噛まれたら死ぬかもしれません
だから瞬間にものすごい恐怖感が生まれるんです
だからまあ 日本でどんな例えに入れ替えた方がいいか分かりませんだけど
まあモコだったらヘビっていうのはもう毎日の別に日常で知っているものだから
どれほど怖いかとも知ってるし
だから踏まれた瞬間で自分も死んだと殺された
もう終わりというものすごい恐怖感でびっくりして飛び上がっちゃうんです
で 実際にその人は暗闇でロープを踏んだことだけなんですね
そこで心がしっかりとヘビを踏んだと
もう殺されるんだという実感が作る
それによって心臓がドキドキする
汗が出るわ もう言葉が出られなくなって
もう喋れなくなっちゃうわ
もうもしかするとその人は意識なくなって倒れる可能性まででもありますよ
でもその人は確実に幻覚を見たんです
で 我々毎日幻覚見てるでしょ
鏡を見て全然幻覚だと思ってないでしょ
あれはまるっきり嘘でしょうに
鏡で見えるものは誰一人それは嘘だと思わないでしょ
鏡で自分の顔見えるはずがないんです
でも鏡の中で自分の顔見える
あるいは正真正銘の幻覚なんです
鏡はそのままもうガラスの板で見えるはずなんですけど
なんでガラスの板で見えないんですかね
もし光が曲がっているんだというならば
なんで曲がってる光見えないんですかね
なんで鏡の中に自分が入れるように見えるんですかね
それまた全く自分じゃないでしょ
全部もう違うんだから
鏡で見えるものは 左は右に見えるし
右は左に見えるし ですから我々よく慣れたもんですよ
鏡のあれ 映像に鏡を見ておしゃれをしたり
いろんなことをしたりするんだけど
実物とは違うんです そういうことで
この本人があ ぴったし決まったぞと思ってるんです
あれ 全く反対の反対の映像を見ているんですね
頭の中で だからでしょう
みんなこの美容師に頼んだり
もっとしっかりした仕事に社会に出たければ
やっぱりそれなりに あの
何て言いますか おしゃれする人々
仕事 スタイリスト そういう人々に頼んでやってもらうでしょうに
その時もたまたま文句言うんです
やってもらう人が いえ
この髪型じゃなくてこの髪型にしてくださいと
あれは自分が鏡で見てそう思うだけのことで
客観的に実物 これはダメですよと
そこでスタイリストがすごい有名な人で
ものすごいお金かかる人だったら
知識暴力で言うことを聞いてくれますけどね
そうでないと文句言うんです
口紅はこの色じゃなくてこの色欲しいんですよ
私は好きですよと 自分が好きでしたけど
あの唇につけたところでどう見えるかっていうことはまた別なもので
本人が鏡で見れば綺麗に見えるかもしれませんだけど
本人にだけ ですから 我々はいつでもすごい幻覚の中にいるんです
そういうことで 出家にお坊さんたちにお釈迦様は鏡で顔を見るなと禁じられてるんです
そういうわけかどうかもう昔はわかってなかったんだけど
一般的にはみんな鏡を見て自分の顔を見たり
お皿するんだと あれはバカバカらしいんだ
やるな あれは俗人やることだと
迷ってる人々 知恵がない人々
汚れてるとやることだと
やるな きちんと戒律でも項目がありまして
ナビッキャレアダーセーナカオムカンオーローケータッバンという
でお釈迦様は昔からしっかり知っていたでしょう
もうだからといって 例えばこのね
顔 何か病気があったりとかね
薬塗らなくちゃいけないとか
そういう場合は見ても構いません
ですから いつでもこの必要な時は見てもいいんだけど
ただもう意味もなく まあこれで決まってるんですかないかっていうか
鏡で見る必要はないんです
で 髭を剃らなくちゃいけないし
頭を剃らなくちゃいけないし
まあその時はまあ鏡を使ってもいいんだけど
よく見ると鏡いりませんよ
もう髭剃る時も頭を剃る時も鏡ない方がものすごい早く剃れるんです
早くてまたぴったしと
私は鏡で見て頭剃ったり髭剃ったりするとどこかで残っちゃうんです
見ないでやる時はどこにも残ってないんです
全部感触でやってますから
その場合は 昨日考えたんだけど
他の人々は髭剃るのを見て
私は頭も髭も剃る時間の八倍ぐらい使っちゃうんです
もう髭だけ剃るために
あれ何やってるんですかと
もう鏡で見て見て見て
もう剃るわ剃るわ 皮膚にも悪いでしょうに
そんなに削っちゃうと
だから結局幻覚の中にいるんですね
剃れたかないかと感触で見ればね
ほんの一分二分で剃れるのに
だから三分あればまあ全部やるんです
自分が で 普通の方々にはやっぱり七
八分かかっちゃうんです
髭だけ剃るために それもまた日本人だから大した髭もないし
ほんのちょっとしかね
あの民族としてあまり髭がない民族でしょうし
で アーリア系の人間だったらね
アフリカ系の アフリカ系もあんまり髭がないんだけど
特にアーリア系の人間っていうのはもう毛だらけですごい髭なんです
だから時間かかるんだったら僕に時間かかった方が合理的なんですけど
僕らはアーリア系の人間だから
ほんのこれとかね ここら辺ちょっとしかないし
まあそこ置いておいて
とにかく我々も毎日日常生活の中でものすごい幻覚の世界にいるんです
ただ気づいてない で その幻覚は私たちにとっては事実だと
全く事実ではありません
この蜃気楼 鏡で見えるもの
それは幻覚なんでしょうし
それでよく怖くなったりもしますね
夜は怖いとか あの人がいないところはものすごい怖いと
不安だと 暗いところは怖い
怖いと あるでしょう で
お釈迦様が悟る前に あの人間のあの恐怖感の研究をしたんです
で どうすれば悟れるかとわかっていなかった時代
この苦行のさせてた時代
で じゃあ私は恐怖感の研究しようと思って
人が怖い怖いといういろんなところに行って
自分で自分を試すんですね
で 全くこの新月で電気ない時代でしょうに
明かりあったっても それは小さな家の中である
これ森の中 それ遺体捨場の
この遺体捨場っていうのは
人は全然行かない遠いところですからね
そういうところにずっと夜いてみるんだそうです
何が怖いかと で 夜お釈迦様こういうのたまにこの夜のね
動く動物いるんだから
鳥なんかささっと夜動く
あのインドだったらクジャクとかね
大型の鳥いるんですね
来てなんかどっかに木の枝に座るんだと
座ったらそれ折れちゃうんだと
で あ